[Aplausos]
una segunda batalla por el liderazgo
Tori en pocos meses y un tercer Primer
Ministro este año es lo que resta tras
la dimisión del issstras el jueves si el
graham Brady jefe del comité que dirige
las elecciones abrió el procedimiento
para encontrar un nuevo líder
conservador una vez más
el proceso para las etapas
parlamentarias de la contienda comenzará
ahora las nominaciones están abiertas
los candidatos necesitarán al menos 100
nominaciones de otros diputados
conservadores para poder presentarse un
umbral alto que significa que un máximo
de tres contendientes disputará en la
batalla Aunque nadie ha declarado
oficialmente su intención de presentarse
Quién es el más probable que acabe en el
número 10
se presentará de nuevo el ex ministro de
hacienda terminó en segundo lugar
después detrás en la batalla por el
liderazgo el mes pasado
otra que recibió un fuerte apoyo fue
Penny la actual líder de la cámara de
los comunes fue la otra candidata que
recibió el apoyo de más de 100 de sus
colegas pero quedó en tercer lugar una
cara conocida que según los informes
está en la carrera es el ex Primer
Ministro Boris Johnson a pesar de haber
dimitido hace apenas unos meses tras
perder la confianza de sus ministros
Johnson se postularía como candidato
sorpresa al número 10 y podría recibir
el apoyo de muchos de sus compañeros
parlamentarios el Secretario de Defensa
ven Wallace también sonó para el cargo
Pero nuevamente decidió no presentarse
si hay más de un candidato que haya
recibido el apoyo necesario antes del
lunes el concurso Se abrirá a los 160
mil miembros del partido conservador en
una votación en línea a la espera de
lograr un nuevo Primer Ministro para el
próximo viernes